this is a worm face and I think that
they are the most disturbing enemy in
Olden ring just listen to the sound they
make are they choking or laughing or
crying their name in The Game's files is
De wrestling which is a French word that
describes someone who has been uprooted
from society and on that note most of
them seem to have had a home within this
forest in the Altus Plateau where they
sit clustered around a minor Earth tree
so considering their location their fine
clothing their holy resistances and
their humanoid is I speculate that they
were once humans aligned with the oak
tree who eventually became disfigured
and defiled by Godwin's death route
after all the worm faces can cause death
blight which itself summons death root
surrounded by worms but in the end
whether they were old tree guardians or
Priests of the old tree or just simple
wood folk who lived in the nearby ruins
no one knows for sure what they are and
if they are laughing well we're
currently not in on the joke and I feel
like that fact just makes them all the
more terrifying